that's also why it's so wonderful that
you know
sites like like locals are springing up
and are going to provide an alternative
nature of warsaw vacuum markets abhor a
vacuum
i love if these twitter guys are going
to are going to youtube are gonna play
the game
the way they want to there's about 47
percent of americans who
want to hear dissident voices and who
will be
really turning tuning in
joining me today is the former ceo of
overstock.com
amanda the renaissance man of e-commerce
by fortune magazine a cryptocurrency
enthusiast
and more patrick byrne welcome to the
reuben report
it is such an honor to be on your show
david it really is perfect i've been
watching you for
four years and just become such an
advisor i feel i've made the big time
this is it man i mean i look i went
through your bio today and i said okay
there's some
there's some impressive stuff here but
this is it this is it
yes no it it it reads better as i say in
theater it all reads better than it
played
my bio but no this is it making it here
is uh i think that you have become such
a
intellectual center of gravity for the
freedom movement that i really am
excited to be
nice thanks well we i appreciate that
and we happened to bump into each other
just a couple weeks ago
it was it was the second time you didn't
even remember the first time because it
was backstage at some yal event or
something
but uh we saw each other we chatted for
a little bit and and this is long
overdue
but you are making a reuben report first
here because just as i sat down a moment
ago
i opened up my twitter to say well
what's patrick up to just so i can ask
him something timely
off the bat and boy oh boy you are doing
something timely
you have been banned from twitter
literally in the last like 10 minutes i
saw your
profile i saw you following me i saw the
tweets
i refreshed just to see if you had put
anything new up
you're gone you're gone so
congratulations
all the all the best people are today
don't you think
what did you do what did you do well
i've been sort of teasing jack
there's a uh there's a tweet someone
should go back a few days ago and find
i put up i something like jack is it for
boaten
to list a 19th century philosopher
a quote from a 19th century philosopher
i've been doing things like that i don't
think i've been violating any terms of
services but just kind of ridiculing
them
john stuart mill wrote this beautiful
statement about
free speech and it was basically he who
knows
only half of uh he only knows his own
side of an argument
only knows half of the argument and it's
not enough to have teachers
tell you what the other side is and then
give you their
how they would answer it that you have
to be able to read the original material
so there has to be free speech that's
the only way
we can have a second discourse and
advance to society
so i put that up i like to think that
that's probably the be kind of funny if
if posting 19th century philosophy
is violating the term if john stuart
mill can get you kicked off twitter i'm
pretty sure
i would be off of twitter so i have a
feeling it might have been something
else but in any event you're off the
twitter
life goes on um real quick i want to
focus really
for for this time on the censorship
stuff on what you think some of the
solutions are on tech
all of that but for the people that just
have no idea who you are you actually
have a pretty fascinating
bio and you've done some really cool
stuff can you can you give me like a
minute or two just like
patrick burn 101 and then we'll dive
into everything that's happening right
now
patrick burn 101 is i had a dual career
in business and academia
part of that's because was i i was got
out of college i had cancer
i three times and i spent a lot of my
20s in the hospital
and for want of something better to do
and convalescing i did a phd in
philosophy
i was something called a martial fellow
and did that
cambridge finish the phd at stanford so
but meanwhile i was also doing all kinds
of other things on the side and those
other things just sort of built
until by the time i was in my late 20s
they were taking they were business
ventures
startups and investments and such and
they kind of took over my life
uh for about 20 25 years i'm happily uh
i left a year ago because i knew that i
was going to be that i had been involved
in a lot of stuff that was going to be
seeing the light of day
and running a publicly traded company as
ceo
i thought it would probably i didn't
know how it was going to come out but i
knew it was going to come out and i
thought it would probably destroy the
company if i stayed
so i punched out a year ago and then
started going
public with some of the things i know
right and some of those things that you
have been tweeting about
are kind of election related stuff that
to be quite frank with you
if i was to bring up right now my
channel could be deleted like that
that's just that's just the sad truth of
it but that's probably the
the segway that'll get us to all the
censorship stuff
uh as a guy that you know you're an
innovator you brought
overstock to ipo you're a crypto guy
you're you're involved in intelligence
and all of these things
what what do you make of this very
bizarre
moment that we're in in terms of the
information war not not even the
specific political
you know trump's got the 10 days left
war
yeah well it's all part is the fourth
stage of a
it's the fourth stage of a psyop and the
first stage was the covid the second
stage was antifa
the demoralization disorientation then
the election whatever happened there we
won't comment on it
but the last stage is normalization
so they have to control the media and
normalize
uh everyone's belief in this election
and if you doubt it everyone's going to
treat you like you're crazy to doubt
this election
so this is really the fourth and final
stage of a psyop where i think they take
over the united states frankly
uh so that that that's why this is so
crucial for them that's also why it's so
wonderful that
you know sites like like locals are
springing up
and are going to provide an alternative
nature of warsaw vacuum markets abhor
a vacuum i love if these twitter guys
are gonna and
are gonna and youtube are gonna play the
game the way they want to
there's about 47 of americans who want
to hear
dissident voices and who will be really
tuning in
so what are you as someone that i think
you're you're pretty much
like me you're you're either an old
school liberal or a libertarian
somewhere in that spot
what do you make of what the government
either should have done or could have
done or would have done
in all of the time that it had to break
these companies up or regulate them or
the rest of it i never felt there was a
good answer you know me i like
competition that's why i started locals
but do you think trump dropped the ball
in terms of
there was a time where maybe some of
this could have been dealt with
yes but i think that they have the goons
have gone to steps that i
doubt even trump anticipated that they
were going to do things like shut off
twitter
for 70 000 people
turn off sights pardon me i know i know
i've coveted as i told you
but i'm i'm surviving you've had it for
a couple days you're alive you're
smiling
live i think i'm on day four it feels
like a
like a mild flu so far um
i'd say uh what
what's they have done is so extreme
that it's really left a bad taste in the
mouth of
anyone but the most crazy marxist
lefties
can't you know they can't imagine in
america
i'm i'm somebody's taking care of me so
that
actually voted for biden and she's she
uh
even she has told me how horrified she
is about what's going on
it's clearly they are showing their hand
and showing america
what the america is that you have to
look forward to in about a week if this
all goes through as planned
so do so okay so if trump couldn't have
foreseen some of this stuff do you think
he just dropped the ball like what would
you have done on the regulation stuff
knowing that these companies were
getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
yet having the
the competition beliefs and the limited
government beliefs
well first of all the um
the emergency broadcast system should
probably have been
extended to social media and not just be
in legacy media
uh the rules of that if the government
needs to communicate they need to
communicate
what if there's a nuclear blast or
something uh or a
threat in addition i think that what
they really have to do is get rid of
this section 230.
you know the whole principle upon which
it was all based and i remember
21 years ago when they made the argument
they said
you can't yahoo says you can't sue us
for stuff that appears on the message
board we're just like a tree in the town
town park and people go and nail
whatever they want on the tree were
value free and on that basis they got
treated not like a publisher who could
be sued for libel but they got treated
like just a neutral platform well
the our concept of a publisher has to
really expand
you become a publisher by using
algorithms that suppress
certain voices and elevate others that
makes you a publisher maybe you're not
the guy
doing the typing but you have
effectively become a publisher
so those those exemptions they have from
the laws on libel that govern say
newspapers
should not be there they shouldn't be
there and there should be guys like nick
sandman suing all these social media
companies
if they if they allow and promote
messages that such as such as a racist
or such-and-such as a fascist and such
then you should be able to sue just like
you can if the washington post
says it or cnn says it and of course we
all know that cnn coughed up
some couple hundred million dollars or
something so they say to nick
so they ought to do that that that same
liability should attach to twitter
youtube everybody else in the game yeah
so do you see the
what happened with the servers to parlor
so moving away from twitter for a second
and just the suppression of whether
they're de-boosting you or shadow
banning you or whether youtube is
suppressing videos
to actually in effect blow up the
servers of
parlor you know they removed this they
didn't physically blow them up but you
know they said you can't use our servers
anymore that's what amazon said
do you view that as just like a massive
escalation or is it just like the
obvious next step
no i do think it's a a massive uh
escalation that should get them sued you
know that should really get them sued
for some great big check
because yeah you can't take your will
you know what if a t and t
go back to the 70s suppose a t had
started saying oh
when you talk on your telephone long
distance
if you are promoting a democrat we're
going to turn you off only republicans
will we let you talk about on our att
phone lines
well i don't know i'd say that it would
have been ridiculous it would have been
ridiculous doesn't matter it's a private
company
uh and so i think it's
it's insidious i think it's
extraordinary but it tells you the kind
of country
we are about to become in the absence of
intervention of one kind or another
you know you've got nancy pelosi saying
that they're gonna round up
children of trump supporters and think
crazy stuff like that
you know if they don't take a vaccine
they're going to take your kids from you
we're really turning into a fascist
fascist stake and i'm sure you
as an as an educated man david
understand that fascism is a phenomenon
of the left
you you were that whole that history
yeah well this seems to be the confusion
because everyone seems to
apply it to the right and to nazism
you but but share with me please
for my for my less educated viewers
well 110 years ago there was a hardcore
socialist in
in italy he ran the socialist paper
avanti he was considered so hardcore he
was almost distasteful to some of the
others
he was a certain type of socialist
called a syndicalist
and you know after marx there's
different strands of socialism and some
strands are the leninist
stalin strand but there was another
strand that was like prudhorn and george
sorel
who believed in worker participation and
worker democracies blah blah
and they ended up evolving this theory
of how to organize society
syndicalism which is basically everyone
belongs to a union
and then the you of different kinds and
then the unions all meet in the halls
the great hall of the government
and with a firm hand of the government
controlling and pushing
they reach their deals and then you as a
minion just live within the deal that
you're
that your guild makes that's socialism
the guy fought in world war one
unlike most socialists and he came back
after world war one and he had a twist
he had a new
frosting which was that yes it is we
socialists who
understand the world correctly but only
we who have been bloodied in battle
really have a place speaking for the
future of the nation
and that this guy's name was as you
probably guessed benito mussolini was
me too mussolini was a hardcore
socialist and
even when he added nationalism he didn't
change how
his view of how you organize society so
you really want to think of there being
two kinds of socialists there's the
international socialists
like the trotsky's and then there's the
national socialists like the mussolini
and then later his pal adolf
but they're they're they're phenomenal
of the left they're not free market guys
or anything like that even
yeah that was all we created after world
war ii that we were taught to think them
as right wing
they grew out of the left are you
shocked that more
people don't know that i mean i i
mentioned i remember when i was on the
young turks when i was a lefty
like five years ago or no it was more
than that now seven years ago or
something like that it feels like ten
lifetimes ago
i remember saying something like that on
air once about well wait a minute
weren't these guys really on the left if
you really know what leftism is and
everyone kind of screaming at me but is
everything that we're seeing now just a
failure of our education system that
nobody knows anything we don't
not only do we not know history we're
actively erasing history
it is indeed i don't know if you're
aware of my
friendship with milton friedman do you
know that story i don't but i'd love to
know it because of course i
have nothing but admiration for milton
friedman
milton thought that the way you saved
the nation was with school choice
and he used to say that our current
government school system or our
socialist
school system is going to teach
socialist values
and a free market system would teach
freedom
uh he saw that's how we saved the
country in the long term
just before he died about a month before
he died he called me and his foundation
was supposed to dissolve at his death
and probably well not probably the
single greatest honor of my life was he
called me and said rose and i want to
change her will
and you're going to carry on in my name
for 10 years as the head of the friedman
foundation which i did
and then stepped down he said carry on
for 10 years and you step down and
change the name to something else
and so i did that for 10 years i think
it's the way i think that so many of the
problems we face these government
schools
he wouldn't call them public schools
government schools uh
have really become little indoctrination
camps it's shocking to me
how how this the nonsense history just
fake history that students get taught
i've
you know working as the ceo of a company
of course interact
with interacted with all kinds of uh you
know age ranges and it's just amazing
how people in their 20s are so
indoctrinated
and they don't know bubkus i don't know
about kids about history
my i love i've got some very close
friends who are
i would call say politely i call them
kind of militant black muslims but we're
good friends
and i we spent we spent a lot of time
debating and stuff
but i'm kind of surprised at least they
know they know a lot but i'm
generally surprised when i deal even
with black activists
how little actual history of of slavery
of black america
do they know they've they've memorized a
bunch of
ideological talking points and spew it
and they can't they
they don't think critically about
anything they've they've memorized
as a general rule which is why you know
i think what's really going on i'm old
i'm a lot older than you we've been
i don't think you're that much older
than me
i got a lot of miles on me as indiana
jones says it's not the ears
uh i used to wonder in the 1980s i lived
in an academic environment
where people were arguing for socialism
and they were still of the mentality
socialism because science and economics
well by the end of the 1980s as that all
collapsed
they were kind of silent for the 90s
then they became socialism because
because of ethics and so there were all
these ethics programs set up at
universities and from what i saw of them
they basically their basic point was if
you're going to be ethical you got to be
a socialist
and then by about 2010 it became
socialism because you're racist then by
about
2015 it became socialism because
shut up and then uh more than the last
couple years have become socialism
because black lives matter
it's all it's all intellectual goo so
and and i wondered where they were going
to go when they
when they ran out of i mean i s i was in
academia when i saw
socialism collapse as a worldwide
movement and i thought these you know
there's always the control freaks
among us they're going to come back
someday with some new way to pitch it
and i've seen in 20 years like i say
there's three or four different stages
so this to me is just you know they
can't even have the arguments anymore
they cannot even conduct themselves
in a in a normal reasoned discourse that
you used to take for granted anyone at a
college could do
and since they can't do that anymore
they don't really want to have the
arguments
they don't want to have any debate they
just want to say
socialism because power have you been
able to figure out
how many sort of how many of them
actually believe it versus how many of
them just go along with it so it's like
i don't think
probably that nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer in their heart of hearts are
are true socialists they might be bigger
government people than we are but i
don't think
they're really socialist in that sense i
sense aoc is probably really a socialist
ilhan omar is probably really a
socialist but what do you make of the
way that they've just sort of
completely been able to eat you know
eat the the last remaining liberals
whatever you want to call them at this
point
well we're i i think of you and myself
as the liberals yeah yeah
i know i'm trying i'm trying it's time
we reclaim our word
there are other words that have been
pejoratives and then the people claim
them it's time we do that
liberalism is what we are they stole our
word about 90 years ago
when it could no longer up until about
90 years ago you could sell socialism
in america as socialism after about 1930
because we were becoming enemies with
the ussr you couldn't call yourself a
socialist
so they started calling themselves
liberals but
they stole our word it's time we we
claim it back
uh i'm sorry so what do i think do i
think that they well i don't know if
nancy pelosi really
she understands power and she wants more
power and more money
and that's all she understands and
that's of course going to lead her down
to endorse increasingly lefty projects
there's there's a book god i haven't
read it in 20 years something like uh
the structure of revolutions destruction
it was about how
about revolutions tend to have a certain
pattern and one of the patterns is
they tend to keep lurching toward the
most extreme
members of the revolution the jacobins
defeat the uh
whatever the guys were called the uh
third estate or africa what they were
called
the bolsheviks defend the men defeat the
benchmarks it's oh it's
the us was the exception our revolution
but when something like this gets going
there's this internal dynamic
where everybody on the side of the
revolution or their revolution
has kind of an incentive to be more
more extreme than the other and that's
why the thing just spills and gets more
more aggressive are you shocked then
that our system i mean i think a lot of
people are watching this going okay
i kind of get it and i kind of feel it
but maybe this guy's
a little bit over the top but are you
shocked
that our system that that so many
conservatives really believe in
libertarians believe in the ideas of the
constitution and the bill of rights and
freedom
and federalism and all of these things
that they were supposed to have systems
that could stand up to this
and it and we're watching the systems
just collect i'm actually right when i
saw you got
banned from twitter the next thing that
i saw was that the democrats are now
trying to push a thing to to ban the
electoral college
like already already
you know what is sad is when you
actually talk when i talk to my
activist friends and if you even ask
them
gee well what is the argument for the
electoral college or
what is the argument for free speech or
or they have no idea they have no idea
they're like a little kid
going into a garden seeing stuff oh i'm
gonna pull that up and look at it
you know they have no idea how anything
actually works and so they want to junk
everything and throw it out and they
have no idea
why the electoral college was a good
idea so i think that they're
i think the thing to know about them is
when you actually engage in discussion
they can't even have intelligent
discussions as far as i can tell
about the background of these rules the
background of property rights the
background of free speech
what is it that made one little clump on
earth
suddenly explode 500 600 years ago and
do so well
that's because we figured out certain
philosophical principles
religious freedom and in general freedom
for your own conscience
all kinds of things worked and they're
just ready to junk them
and they can't even tell you they don't
know anything i'm so disappointed
actually when i talk to activists it's
shocking to me
even on the subject of black america and
slavery
they know nothing about the history of
slavery they just have some talking
points
no they they don't do serious work it's
so interesting because i just covered
this i'm sure you saw
this biden speech where he's talking
about covid relief and he says well
we're going to help black and hispanic
and pacific islander and blah blah blah
first
and it's like that's actually against
the constitution
that's against the forget that mlk guy
it's against the constitution that we
don't curry favor
based on the color of your skin and yet
it's so brazenly being pushed on us
by the guy they told us was the moderate
right and if you go along with it
if you have a society like that then you
need a government agency that's the
department of who's been naughty and
nice
who's the one who gets the who the bad
treatment who's the one who gets the
good treatment
once you have a government agency of
who's been naughty and nice or whatever
they call it
uh making decisions like that then you
have this
you know that's just it's a terrible
solution anyone any child
can will know what's going to happen
over a decade if that
in a government where the government is
trying to fine-tune
things like that and it just creates
this this pandering
citizenry who think their job is to
supplicate
to the government who's going to be the
one and you know i'm going to make an
argument about why i've
not been naughty and i'm nice and he's
been the one who's been naughty and it
just tears society apart
in that in that way it's terribly
unhealthy and there's no evidence
whatsoever does anything but create
disasters as far
you know i lived in i lived in communist
china in 83 84 when they first opened up
and i saw a lot of this stuff unfolding
there
and it's yeah it's kind of it's their
lack of education
makes them not understand what the
necessary consequences
of having government get in the business
and deciding who's been naughty and nice
and giving special
favors to it just turns the holes aside
into this corrupt
throne sniffing supplicant to the powers
that be in government
what do you really feel patrick what do
you really feel
it's throne sniffing i don't think you
can say thrones
no please the whole mainstream media is
going to be thrown sniffing for the next
four years so
uh yeah oh wait so so bringing this back
to the big tech part because
uh you were running over stock you
you're well known in the crypto world
and all that when when people look at
these guys like zuckerberg or like jack
dorsey at twitter or the rest of them
and they i think a lot of people think
that they're they're sort of these
inherently evil
characters where i'm a little more
sympathetic to the human condition of
they're managing these
virtually unmanageable things i think
they do have a lot of the bad ideas that
you're talking about
i think they've shown themselves to to
you know only
censor one side the whole thing do you
have any sympathy as a guy that's run
big businesses
that with the type of stuff that they
have to manage these days
and the pressures from government or or
to the millions make up for it
that they're getting paid the hundreds
the millions make up for it
no i don't have any sympathy the really
the way to handle it
is just keep everything simple keep the
truth the truth
and keep keep the rules simple simple
rules for a complex world
if you start getting in the business of
censoring by content by viewpoint you
know
then you then you in in facebook are
going to need your department of who's
been naughty and nice
it's a terrible road to go down i
actually uh
i gotta tell you i don't all i know
about zuckerberg
is this chinese i hate to be a mandarin
snob but it's chinese stinks
in about six weeks of studying chinese
this guy's been married to a chinese
woman for 10 years
his chinese sounds to me like
probably minded after about six weeks of
study at dartmouth college it's
and that tells me a lot this guy studied
it for years got a chinese wife
he's his chinese is so grating it tells
me
you know he he just came up with a good
idea well he must be real smart in other
ways not everyone is
uh although it could be he just stole
the ideas of course i did see the movie
i didn't see the movie how is your
mandarin now
do you want to send some sort of message
to our new chinese overlords that maybe
the youtube sensors won't uh
well i guess they'd be happy about it
i am a great admirer of the chinese
you can get you have that to uh oh yeah
you can turn that into a
native speaker they can translate so
yeah it's a shame i
love china and this is probably a
dangerous thing to admit i'm a
i'm an old china hand i grew up loving
china i uh
i saw it as my if i had a historical
role in the world
it was going to be to somehow build i
think
the best thing that could happen for the
world is some sort of merger of the u.s
and chinese principles
that actually could create a healthy
perpetual piece for the world we have a
lot to learn from the chinese they do
some things very well their
family their traditions their focus on
education and building
human capital all kinds of things i i
saw in china and i thought boy this is
what we need to see more of here
but what i love about our system is
freedom and there needs to be some sort
of merger
of those of those interests and i'm i if
they may not be really the ultimate guys
behind this
uh they may be involved it may be
somebody else the truth will come out
uh i think sooner rather than later but
uh i if they have been involved in this
all i can say is it's a real
disappointment to me because i spent my
whole life
thinking of them as my friends i kind of
love them almost as much as i do america
frankly
so i have to say in in full transparency
when
when we met uh just a couple weeks ago
you said to me hey dave you know i
really like what you're doing
um and you i think you said something
about locals.com and i said oh well
maybe we should talk
we literally got on the phone like a day
later i had you meet my
my business partner about two days later
you you immediately invested
um so you do own a piece of locals.com
which is
thrilling for us and i think you're
gonna help us navigate these really
freaking uh these nasty waters basically
these really rough waters that we're
about to go through
um is there something i'll do it
publicly is there something we should be
thinking about as this company's growing
right now in the midst of all of this
that that maybe i'm not thinking about
yet
i uh
keep the faith i do not think we're
going to lose this
i actually think that we're going to win
keep keep the faith
uh i i would say that they they said
metric capital bet the jockey and not
the horse
when i met you that's i knew i wanted to
bet on you as the jockey
uh at least as much about that as your
fundamental underlying idea however
what you what you spoke to me about with
locals sounded so
precisely uh matching my view of the
world and what was needed
and a way to be off off the the main
platforms in a way they could not come
after
which i think when we spoke about it we
thought it might be some distant
abstract
we didn't realize it three weeks i
didn't realize three weeks
you know but at least a month least in
mind
what's what's next for you well
i'm gonna see how this plays out over
the next week
and then uh and then i'm gonna take it
easy
i sort of just had a tough year and a
half and since i left the company
and we're going to see how this plays
out then i'm going to take it easy
probably
go lay somewhere warm in the sun is what
i need to do i probably should be doing
it right now
but go lay in the sun and some tropical
location is what i really love to do
that sounds like a plan well patrick i
i'm thrilled that we finally did this
i'm thrilled that we're
partnered up on locals and
we shall see we shall see what happens i
normally don't end a show like that but
i feel like that's the best i got right
now like
we shall see right may you live as the
chinese say may you live in
uninteresting times yeah unfortunately
we got the interesting times which i
know is a chinese curse that's the
problem
right but i'll be watching uh i'll be
watching locals with great interest and
i think
i think half of america is
is fed up with this censorship they're
going to gravitate very quickly
to what you have to like well i wish i
could tell people to follow you on
twitter but you are suspended
where can i send them at least is there
any other place i can send them
deep capture deepcapture.com you
captured that's what i've been writing
for about 15 years when i have something
to tell the world i put it up there
great
awesome well thank you so much and feel
better drink some oj
we'll talk soon if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about tech instead of non-stop yelling
check out our tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell